okay volunteer our last presenter
professor hikita she is associate
professor College of imaging argument
arts and sciences with at resume the
university so um she also served as a
kiss creators in the National Film
Center which is as a state national
state I mean state archive in Japan so
on her publications include it is it
volumes such es llamado g nigga was good
images from making and image database in
studies of Japanese arts and cultures
and also either local phone co GI so i
should say the time of the time of haha
she looked like
so as you see from her allegations she
is a scholar of japanese film studies
but also in a hurricane position she is
very much involved with various archival
works like such as restoring a film um
unfortunately we don't have a time how
to introduce her like other aspect of
her work but like she's bestow she is
her doubt that I Tiamat ritsumeikan
University which restored 1930s film me
saco de as sort of a musical film made
in a local took the coding prefecture in
japan um so today she is going to
discuss um yes pics a small gosh Phil
culture in pre-war Japan please welcome
our history
let's square image its commitment from
back in a collection others are language
on fast iraq to say thanks to Professor
under object data and dr. noguchi
address and professor Corey for giving
me this great opportunity I feel honored
to participate in this scenario but at
the same time I hope my English will be
good enough because this is my fast
english presentation in my life and
thanks to my wonderful English teacher
and I'm very a very Japanese yes so
there are three reasons and chose this
topic the first reason is that it
arrested mr. Martinez original topics
his research started on japanese
documentary Special floki no I explain
later so his collection hundreds the
augmentation of small gas filled
umbrellas of them and that's why he
looked at salford the principal streams
and fairest of small gas film history
improvised of them the second reason is
that I have a personal attachment to the
plant in operation around 99 t mr.
machina produced researcher in Kawasaki
stream museum where I worked as a
pattern alchemists at the time physic
film announced it took developing a
mimetic will hold its a chrome so we
were preparing a symposium on the admin
meta film movement and so I
the opportunity to do research on small
European history at mr Mackey no scars
where my police the third reason is the
problem that we don't have enough
archives 40 in Japan in America there
are many activities by archives and
universities for smokers film and there
are some books about it but it the disc
and but in Japan there are fused so we
need to pay more attention to this
problem I think the end of the aim of my
report is to gratify the unique
viewpoint we can get about this report
through the magnification for this
purpose and we focus on difference
between differences between general
streams and Japanese students in the
small girls film in pre-war especially
about the integration of several streams
and artists to the national propaganda
film in wartime first of all I want to
be sure everyone here understands what
is mint meant by small base film
smugglers where is everybody release of
the film the standard grace is satisfied
no matter which is mainstream mainstream
used in movie theaters others are
substandard goose small gaze means under
satisfied pardon me later for example 28
miniature 17.5 namita 16 mamita nine
point five meters ahead and so that
gives on the other terms means over 35
for example 17 a leader in freiburg
japan around 19 23 9.5 minute and 16
millimeter had been introduced and by
the late twenties had already become
widely used then eight millimeter had
been introduced in the nineteen thirties
and began to be replaced by 1.5 meter in
great circles these three ladies became
mainstream nine-point millimeter was a
product called party baby produced by
french film company fat affair bank shot
and was the main company to sell them
and also make films and equipment for
9.5 monitor users of 9.5 minute are
often called themselves baby party baby
talk and created some class called
babies nima baby lima and so on
16-millimeter and edna meter bar
products by eastmancolor at the
beginning eastman billion to sell
project rose called for the scope and
movies called horoscope library then
this old cameras called nevada these
product products and the way they were
marked it bought the same as in other
countries the center of Eastman product
in your parents in equinox service japan
in osaka at the beam users of 60
millimeter an eight millimeter used cars
amateur movies amateur movie maker
indifferent to their crafts and
themselves and their national flag pole
amaris memory as you see
sonali which was created with the
american club in new york and both of
them used a bug small years film for
attaullah as a neutral meaning in
contrast to vaguely and amateur this
small guest frame is defined as smaller
than 35 millimeter so it includes
professional rocks for example culture
films educational films newsreels and in
the world to the contrary amateur film
is defined as a young professional video
focus of amateurism so it includes
amateur 35 new meta plows in japan since
nineteen forty-one this neutral lot
smaller film replaced the American word
about your theory then the second step
is about smugglin spin what are some
aspects of there are six points as you
see the first point is the funding in
simple easy and flexible it is
lightweight and convenient for
individual consumer so our product
companies also used women and children
in their advertisement that even women
and peaceful yes especially for a few is
too violent and comparte from part a
used to children are you feel this point
are the same for Japanese advertisement
but they are very modern & bossier for
Japanese I think of the right one is our
mother issues
active at risk oh yes and Zimmerman said
the image of the woman's natural eyes
and humanized a technology in Japan nine
point five millimeter was called kicks
toy and baby for babies baby which steam
it baby part is prime then finally ended
up changing the name of the analogy from
Venice lemma to Patty's me although many
still turns the baby references if you
read the consumers horse farm in their
magazine you can find that well consumer
said I will marry miss Pearl Bailey the
second point is that it's more
economical and certified limited along
1930 in Japan's the other is monthly
basis of university graduates were
around 69 am at that time the price of
color for 9.5 inventor was 90 m and for
460 Miata it was 400 from 452 800
billion about the price of projector for
9.5 miniature was 19 and for 60 meter it
was 540m about obviously these losers
are mainly upon your clansmen and
student club members as mr. gyro
mentioned and teachers the third point
is that it is safe it wastes which means
that it was not the fine what the file
parser
the standard case because of this valve
are recognized as home and spoonfuls the
light image is interesting about the
minim for the first class of educational
film contest by baby cinema the film was
the power of great nature beautified
stamatopoulos who I will mention later
the first point is that developing and
print services are readily available
this is about the product system kadavo
be said you press the button we do the
rest impress dilemma bitterest but
japanese amateur filmmakers like to
develop their own films to get the
images they wanted they also want about
exposure through this process so they
lacked part a baby for the work in the
reversal process we have space tools or
electric power filmmakers developed
party baby film the one half of
developing solution and sunlight the
bits point is that a screen image is not
as good as certified network of course
so on collapse or special screening
tools as you can see right from the
advertisement but Japanese baby party
backed up what are a special ways to
scream mer without using special tools
by using canned paper as a screen
between white paper they introduced
their way in the magazines so very
partied with having big screenings that
those thickness you see the sixth point
is that they have many types of film for
example color panchromatic film and Toki
this is Toby system this Toki that means
that in Japan before turkey and Clara
things was shown in a movie theater we
saw them and made things at all the next
step is to examine what kind of cultural
contribution we have gotten from smog a
spring in people there are four topics
the first is examples and filmmakers for
movie Deadshot apologies very at the fun
in life travel I whiskey foliage or
hobby and experimental film animated
film cultural film it because no
animated film in Japan and mention about
three jungles underlined as the unique
point the past is a mountain fence which
mountain climbers should sit is called
Santa hood Ella like honored family the
director is schematically as I mentioned
already he was a real winner of birth
process winner of film techniques for
for example shooting developing and so
on and he was a responsible for lot of
developments in the field of attachment
for 1.5 millimeter for example Islands
fail crime and he also was a regular
judge in confessed he was the most
frequently on an amateur filmmaker
especially 9.5 but in 1933 the
proportion of the national policy for
movies a box of champion must adopt it
and step by step the Japanese government
strongly
permettez create clear-cut on the film's
however this policy was not to strictly
enforced antoinette 1937 when the
government plan the banned the import of
all film stock as a result controlled by
the government of films and content
became severe and amateur exhibitors
welcome find prevalent in sales finally
amateur filmmakers have to pass the
master filmmaker skill it's a mission to
receive a license to show their work to
the public it became extremely difficult
for amateur filmmakers to mega movie
freely and Yamato who was highly
esteemed in the small gasping world
active as trust of the propaganda film
contest and also as the examiner of the
National informations at that time
squamata acting as a just to examine
whether a fair comply with natural for
sea lions brought the production of
mountain films administration in this
essay he wrote about the strong
connection between mountain climbing
footage and the national polls he made
sure that the purpose of for making
Mountain films was considered an
essential contribution to the war effort
and the Film Commission he wrote that
mountain climbing is autism related to
the mental part in physical education
campaign at the same time related
directly to national defense if the
quadrant is dead
on the front which we can do as our part
in the defense of the home front at the
mountains our production the part which
most pure and stronger in portrays the
natural beauty of the country of our
ancestors and store found to feel pure
about the country of our ancestors he
said as a conclusion the mountain fields
elevates the pathetic mind but he also
want at the beginning of this essay the
mountain let us forget the lands of the
world and give us the power of
meditation he worried that amateur
filmmakers would not be able to come up
with a suitable production purpose under
the emergent situation which was big
enough to be accepted by an examiner so
they wouldn't be able to make any films
at all he also wrote may I know that my
holy smokers film can be a little
helpful to our nation natural cause I am
glad to borrow it was a respectable
probably so oh man can feel the
similarity between this essay and the
others it says he had written in which
she describes his alternate technics to
the berry party in the analogy this is
self portraits to a mirror interference
one is the speed of smokers film
production as amateurish and the week
struction an explanation of mobile and
appearance and the second am very
material is that the pride has the
substandard and consciousness of the
mainstream thinking substandard in such
small gifts film this ambivalent
feelings so the characteristic of the
Japanese smokers film culture the second
is about portal film especially the
protein of movement and two directors in
a few other point are indirect activity
and influence of director SAS again
jewel and external episode blocking of
instead abbreviated bank of the world
called upon prohealth keener you in
Esperanto they were the first to use
films as weapons in Japan and it began
in 1927 with such as film mail day in
Tokyo 1927 in 1.5 millimeter sasser
published his famous he told the phone
camera as a manifesto of the struggle
indian-origin in 1928 of course the
title told weapon camera is in reference
to 9.5 minute they have made simple
original films in 9.5 enter an innovator
and they also did 12 and screaming as
propaganda but there are movements were
crushed in 1934 by severe person and
then some niggas having being
we're a release from prison we get to
work in cultural educational and
governmental film under Japanese
propaganda system as I already mentioned
sasha has worked as an editor and
punished of frontal film yoga yoga this
one from 1930s to the nativity scene
actually um pouquinho Sasha wrote an
essay colony film in which he authorized
educational films as propaganda under
the corner policy of the capitalistic
state when you find strong similarity
between this essay and his activities in
Blanca era as if it was theory and
practice Stella lokito was also one of
the leaders and he worked at the
Manchurian production a big trunk line
schooling and made from an interference
from Manchuria he insisted on the
importance of small gas film as national
propaganda in his assist struggle acted
with small this film and from material
especially about traveling screenings
and their contents continuing with the
same struggles next the second topics is
community they made their own class in
each movement difference from shooting
days contest and published magazine the
same as in other countries photo shops
in eastern border their symptoms as
cultural sounds in Japan and the clamp
niggas was in baby cinema showed these
crafts and members objectives in
articles written by the members with the
writers name being included in Makkah
bleep there are more things about
members living in Korea Manchuria Taiwan
and distant places that about other
members the joyful reported there are
typical divers i will try gather in
france as much as possible to show the
power of fatty baby from the nose in
chosen i'm sure that three people join
the party party really think you after
really thank you for your painting the
important fields to us and the famous
director advisor of the baby euskara hio
brought his joy about members of cookies
embarrassing Emma Congrats organized
clubs in spite of the unimaginable
isolation and the remoteness of some of
the island
and borders saying this makes me glad to
utilize true significance of small girls
film so once I see that 9.5 my meta
materials at the balances connected
individual and the remote areas colonies
to the center craft in Tokyo as if
they'll be well a device to help share
the common identity of the people in the
national scale or very common the
formation of employers about the size of
it is family island till it is the
status of the modern above middle sorry
it is the status of the modern upper
middle class which enables making and
watching movies of family right at the
home and also enjoy nature's convince
having home theater in Japan these are
the symbols of modern life and culture
especially American culture with
Japanese glance through the peers third
advertisement and articles of small desk
film one can see how much the Japanese
had read a dimension for American
culture and products for example Eastman
Kodak film token system 16 and 16
millimeter connected with amateurs
anomaly in New York colorful Baron of
our camera and content gets lots of
American culture directly for example
during wartime off with an overall food
is a pioneer of Germany admission taught
how to make animated film in his essay
specific making real truth he picked up
some chakra
and franchise as textbooks thankee
inoculated closely their governments and
expression he ended his cell with this
sentence Donald is very an ideal and
mention amazing it is the masterpiece of
modern times this is just one chest but
one can see the smoke gets home
libraries in American culture filter
into Japanese cultured people it may be
said that it is intentional are you
taking identification with American
culture the last topic is familiar see
that is making clear but in the cross my
heart Marty way and screening watching
frames in daily life private unlimited
viewing to record the Prince momentum
time is to infiltrate our daily life
these contents and films are individual
Diaries histories and memories so small
girls film culture deeply intensified
the influence of the power of film of
our lives and at the same time there are
our corporate memory at last my
conclusion the aspects third which we
can understand and appreciate your
mechanical shop are fast the process and
dynamism of the several different string
and octopus-like baby process sixty
millimeter each club genres honorable
amateur filmmaker poking of traveling
screening but integrated gradually
to the national conscience and
mainstream propaganda second in the
second is an aspect of smokers frame was
that it was a diverse to form the common
identity of the people in the nation
state of india japan in japanese case
this device connected to the extremes of
thinking and doing work which could be
categorized as standard and substandard
between 35 millimeter other and 60
millimeter at nine point five millimeter
professional and amatuer the center and
the remote area not go straight until
video the same as work and file in this
case one is always mainstream and the
another is substring always the
substring had read file but at the same
time they might have adored the
mainstream the third is final formation
of a dimension for american culture
society and product
you